i'm shannon bream i'm bill hemmer i'm
kennedy and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday december 1st
2021
i'm dave anthony
pro-choice advocates are nervous
about the abortion case a more
conservative supreme court considers
today if the court were to toss out roe
then obviously each state would be
allowed
to ban abortion uh 12 states have
indicated that they would do so
alisa brady omicron has begun what could
be a march around the world and it may
not be covid's last twist still jury out
but uh we're hoping this one does not
prove to be as bad as uh as it could be
but um it's just a matter of time if we
don't step up our game
and i'm jason chaffetz i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
it's what pro-life activists have hoped
for and what pro-choice advocates fear
a case before the supreme court today
that could potentially undo roe v wade
the 1973 decision that legalized
abortion in the u.s at issue a 2018
mississippi law to ban most abortions at
15 weeks of pregnancy which lower courts
ruled violates a woman's rights but
governor tate reeves says they're
standing up for the rights of the unborn
since roe was enacted 62 million
american babies have been aborted and
have therefore been killed governor
reeves a republican told nbc's meet the
press sunday i believe very strongly
that if you read the constitution there
is nowhere in the constitution that
prohibits individual states states like
mississippi to limit access
to abortions but this case and issue go
beyond just roe v wade and could reset
court precedent it is indeed perhaps the
most consequential abortion case in
decades jonathan turley is a george
washington university law professor a
court and constitution expert and fox
news contributor this case for those who
oppose roe v wade has all of the
elements of a rogue killing case that
doesn't mean it'll happen
but while people often in the past have
exaggerated the impact of
or the potential impact of past cases
this is the real mccoy if there's a
majority of justices that disagree with
roe
dobbs versus jackson women's health
organization is
exactly what they wanted
this case
though isn't necessarily a direct
challenge to row we've talked before
and at issue might be a different
supreme court case after roe v wade
legalized abortion correct that's right
a lot of people misunderstand that after
row you had the decision in casey which
basically gutted roe what it kept was
the essential
recognition in row
of the protected right to an abortion
but it dispensed with the whole
trimester
framing that justice blackman created in
row and it replaced instead this
standard which is rather fluid of
states not imposing undue burdens on
this right
now that has led to a great deal of
litigation
as to what constitutes undue burden
and much of the attention is along this
line called viability that the idea is
that states were presumed
to be barred from substantial
limitations on abortion
pre-viability
and then after viability the ability of
states to legislate increases
that line could be at issue here even if
the court does not
overturn roe and casey
i it could
change the standard to allow states to
have more leeway in legislating in the
area of reproductive rights
okay so if i'm not mistaken the line in
casey
a state may not prohibit any woman from
making the ultimate decision to
terminate her pregnancy before viability
how is that a gray area well it's gray
as to what constitutes
pre-viability
the problem with a lot of the uh supreme
court precedent particularly roe and to
some extent casey
is that it's at conflict with technology
that was particularly the case with roe
that
uh technology made viability an earlier
and earlier
option that
medical science simply allowed for
preemie babies to survive in earlier and
earlier stages so that led the court in
casey to say well we can't have that but
even the casey standard
retains this important line of viability
and so what some people are arguing is
that that has moved forward since casey
and so therefore the mississippi law
with a 15-week limit
is appropriate that after 15 weeks
you can prohibit abortion
now mississippi's governor a republican
tate reeves said the other day that he
believes very strongly that there's
nowhere
in the constitution which is clearly
dates back a long time
to prohibit states from limiting access
to abortions
is he
on the right path there or
bringing the constitution in is that
really not an issue here well bringing
the constitution into this is an issue
and that the court
is going to be asked uh in this uh oral
argument uh to
uh reverse roe and to say precisely as
was just stated that
uh the constitution does not create this
constitutional right rho is a
constitutionally based decision okay and
it is certainly true that the
constitution doesn't refer to abortion
it doesn't even refer to privacy the
question is how do you interpret that uh
most people agree that this that the
constitution protects privacy but
privacy isn't mentioned
but a lot of challenges are saying that
abortion was a crime
when the constitution was written in
many states it had long been treated as
a crime in england
so the framers could not have foreseen
that this constitution would contain
that type of protection but others would
say that well that just means the
constitution evolves with time the
meaning of these protections expands
with time okay so
what are the options for this supreme
court in a ruling in this case
well one option is in the threshold
question is whether there are now five
justices that believe that roe is simply
bad precedent
uh
we have
justices on the court that in the past
have questioned the viability of row
itself as a conventional doctrine and
now we have six potentially six
conservatives on the court
that's right including justice barrett
who wrote a rather lengthy analysis of
roe that challenged its constitutional
footings when she was a law professor
but if they do not have those votes and
you might have chief justice roberts
justice kavanaugh
get a little bit of a sticker shock in
overturning row i think that many of the
uh
pro-choice advocates are hoping they can
lure
uh
roberts and kavanaugh to the middle on
that issue
the default then becomes do you want to
change the standard itself while
allowing row to remain on the books
after all casey radically changed row
and maybe it's time to radically change
kc
now on that there's some interesting
arguments even the washington post has
confirmed that the united states is only
one of seven countries in the world out
of 198
that allow for abortions after the 20th
week of pregnancy so our standard
currently is towards the
high end of protection on abortion
also there's historical arguments being
made that
many of the early discussions of
abortion talked about the quickening and
the quickening is when a
pregnant woman first feels movement of a
fetus
that would ten that largely occurred
around the 15th or 16th week of a
pregnancy well that happens to be the
line used in mississippi it's around the
same time 15 16 weeks while the justices
consider mississippi's abortion law
today
texas's even stricter new law is still
going through the courts with abide in
administration trying to get it
overturned arguing it's unconstitutional
that law bans most abortions when a
fetus's heartbeat is detected around six
weeks
so how could that case be affected by
what the supreme court decides on
mississippi if the court were to toss
out roe then obviously each state would
be allowed uh to ban abortion uh 12
states have indicated that they would do
so
i but if they keep roe it's extremely
unlikely that they would uphold a law
like texas what's interesting is that
the united states court of appeals for
the fifth circuit will be hearing an
argument in that case
uh
this week so as the court is considering
dobbs the fifth circuit is going to give
an expedited hearing to whole woman's
health versus jackson which is the case
dealing with the texas law with that
much earlier uh prohibition
so you have both cases being argued
roughly at the same time
a lot of
people like to listen to these arguments
from the supreme court especially the
one wednesday with mississippi and will
read into what the justices
might rule based on the questions that
are asked do you think that's good
practice or is that a mistake to do that
no i think it's good this is a case
where oral argument really could give us
an insight into where these justices
are everyone will be watching justice
kavanaugh chief justice roberts and
justice barrett to see
if they are coming from just one side in
those questions but it's often a
precarious practice to
judge too much on those types of
questions for example whole women's
health versus jackson the one the case
in front of the fifth circuit
that issue the texas law came before the
supreme court not once but twice the
supreme court refused to continue the
injunction on that law
and then when it came back again the by
demonstration basically asked the same
question again and said were you
enjoying this
many people thought that the the
expedited hearing that we all listened
to indicated that the court would be
enjoining the law well they didn't they
didn't do anything at all
what about the other trump appointee
neil gorsuch
well gorsuch is going to be interesting
as well he is someone who
goes back to first principles i
testified at his confirmation hearing
and one of the things that i said was
that
gorsuch is someone who does not get
sticker shock uh he tends to vote
according to what he thinks the
constitution means uh he tends to make
that decision by returning to first
principles as to the text and the
original intent
and he is not someone
that tends to
tailor that analysis uh because of how
it will be received or whether people
have relied on a doctrine all right and
then of course
this is you know december 1.
we won't know an answer from the court
this might be one of the last decisions
we get right sometime in june
it could be i mean they always can
expedite a decision the other
interesting aspect is that they still
have this live torpedo in the water they
were asked to enjoin the texas law
the fifth circuit's going to do an
expedited opinion on that law they could
still take action there i
so they've got a number of options to
telegraph where they are
but you're absolutely correct we're
going to have to wait to see how this
plays out
jonathan turley george washington
university law professor fox news
contributor always good to get your
insight thank you
thank you
[Music]
this is jason chaffetz with your fox
news commentary coming up
no one knows for sure yet just how bad
the new cobit variant is or isn't but
less than a week since south africa
sounded the alarm about detecting it the
list of countries with confirmed cases
is growing quickly now including france
japan and brazil rattling financial
markets again fed chief jay powell
telling a senate panel rising cases in
general plus the variant could impact
employment and inflation greater
concerns about the virus could reduce
people's willingness to work in person
which would slow progress in the labor
market and intensify supply chain
disruptions health officials are still
offering hope dr anthony fauci says as
with the delta variant the effectiveness
of vaccines may be somewhat diminished
but not entirely we don't know what that
degree of diminution of protection is
going to be but we know that when you
boost somebody you elevate your level of
protection very high and we are hoping
and i think with good reason to feel
good that there will be some degree of
protection which means keeping more
people out of the hospital and alive in
the meantime the cdc also recommends
masking in public indoor settings in
areas with substantial cova transmission
which right now is more than 80 percent
of u.s counties thanks mainly to the
delta variant well my first reaction
when i heard about omicron was uh well
we knew this was going to come and
hopefully it's not as bad as we're
thinking it could be doctor and former
u.s surgeon general jerome adams we know
that until we get more of the united
states and more of the world vaccinated
and right now we are still at less than
60 percent of the country of the u.s
vaccinated and certainly far less than
that of the world vaccinated that we are
going to continue to see variants and
we as scientists have always said that
we just hope we don't get the nasty one
is more transmissible and more severe
and evade their vaccines and so uh still
jury out but uh we're hoping this one
does not prove to be as bad as uh as it
could be but um it's just a matter of
time if we don't step up our game
i know the much
higher number of mutations with this
variant seems to be driving a lot of the
concern
from my understanding that sets it apart
from both delta and possibly the
existing vaccines do i have that right
correct what's important for people to
understand is that as long as the virus
is replicating then it is mutating and
not every mutation in fact most
mutations don't result in a meaningful
change to how the virus behaves
clinically but every now and then you
get a mutation which may make the virus
more transmissible or contagious you
make a mutation which makes the virus
more severe or you may get a mutation
which causes antibody and immune evasion
which means vaccines and therapeutics
don't work anymore what's really scary
about omicron is that it has over 50
different mutations
in it and that
we've seen those mutations in areas that
affect transmissibility severity and in
antibody evasion at least in the
laboratory setting
is the world at this point at this early
stage when we there's a lot that we
don't know about it aside from the you
know number of mutations
uh is the world overreacting from
financial markets to governments to
people in general are we taking it too
seriously or not seriously enough
well one thing that the president said
recently was that we should prepare but
that we shouldn't panic and we shouldn't
panic again from a scientific standpoint
we
expected that this was going to happen
we will continue to see mutations so no
there's not a need for panic just yet
but uh it's a good time for us to
reflect on the many tools that we've
received over the last year to be able
to combat this virus and to double down
on those tools so that uh if this isn't
as serious as many of us fear that it
could be that we are prepared for the
next time when it might be more serious
is the us in particular doing a good
enough job
tracking variants and i asked this in
part because south africa is getting
praise from the us and others for
spotting this and alerting the world to
it though there's information now that
this variant may actually have already
been in europe
before
that at least several days before that
so how do we actually know that it's not
here in the u.s if we're not constantly
looking
it's important for people to understand
how we track this virus and one way we
track this virus is by testing
just so that we know who's who's um
popping up positive and one of the
challenges we have with anagen testing
the rapid testing out there is that even
when people test at home they aren't
reporting if they're positive
unfortunately we haven't seen a
substantially increased availability of
pcr testing traditional laboratory
testing or of antigen testing to the
extent that we were promised originally
by the by the current administration so
that's the first part the second part is
once people do start to turn up positive
we want to do genomic or genetic testing
so that we can determine if this is the
same variant that's uh circulating in
the united states it's delta or whether
it's a new variant but the honest truth
is many scientists myself included
believe that the variants already here
we just uh haven't tested for it and
haven't done the genomic sequencing to
be able to identify it yet
what in your opinion should the federal
government's next steps be
well i think the federal government
needs to number one
uh have a more sensible and a more
ethically sound policy in terms of
travel restrictions there are over a
dozen countries not on the travel
restriction list
that have confirmed cases uh i was in
support of travel restrictions earlier
on in the week when uh when we first
heard about this in the hopes that it
would give us a pause and an opportunity
to prepare
but that was also when the only cases we
knew about were in south africa again
now over a dozen different countries
have reported these cases so uh i think
the president needs to come out and
either expand travel restrictions uh or
needs to take them off of south africa
because it comes across as very racist
to say that only uh this part of the
world is on the travel ban list now that
said um i i don't say this to say that
we shouldn't do anything um we actually
in my opinion should have a strategy
that allows people to travel back and
forth perhaps with a pcr test uh 24 to
72 hours before they board a flight
combined with a rapid test when they're
boarding the flight and that can be done
in 15 minutes to confirm you're not
immediately positive when you get on the
flight and one of the other things
that's troubling is that the uh the
policy was only for people from south
africa it wasn't for us nationals it
makes no scientific sense to think that
if the virus is circulating there that
u.s citizens who come back from there
aren't going to carry it with them and
so we need a more sensible policy to
help us deal with this virus we need to
be ramping up genetic sequencing here in
the united states 20 other countries are
ahead of us in terms of their ability to
sequence this virus and find out what's
going on and we need true engagement in
terms of boosters and vaccinations and
not this shaming and blaming that's been
going on largely along political lines
because that is our best protection
right now
the new variant has reignited a debate
about whether travel bans really help
reporters asking president biden on
tuesday how long u.s restrictions on
several southern african nations will be
in effect he said it's a week to week
decision we're going to learn a lot more
in the next couple weeks about the
lethality of this virus about how much
it spreads about
whether what we have can control it etc
the administration is reportedly
considering tougher testing requirements
for all international travelers to the
u.s and possibly self-quarantines with
the president expected to detail next
steps on thursday but what about a
return to more masking or capacity
limits at restaurants
well i think you are going to see more
restrictions one of the great things and
one of the frustrating things about this
wonderful country of ours is that the
states have most of the public health
authority and so you're already seeing
some states cracking down on ability to
people to gather in public without
mitigation measures and you're going to
see other states that um continue to say
let her rip until such time as their
hospitals get overwhelmed the answer is
almost always somewhere in the middle
it's not on the extreme that somewhere
in the middle i think if we continue to
be smart we get vaccinated if we get
boosted if we're smart when we're in
public around people who we don't know
and make sure we're keeping our distance
and or we're outside and or we're well
ventilated and or we're wearing masks in
those settings then uh then we can stay
open but i think if we go the way of of
just throwing caution to the wind then
you're going to see
delta continue to spread and where we
can be in real trouble even if omicron
doesn't turn out to be the threat that
many people fear it is
that's so hard
psychologically to think about that
maybe
there is no real end in sight do we need
to adjust our thinking about what an end
to this pandemic looks like
we absolutely need to adjust our
thinking and i've said this
for several months now you had both
administrations both a trump
administration and a biden
administration who in my opinion wanted
to declare victory over this virus far
too early
and what we learned was that we don't
make the timeline the virus makes the
timeline
and what we can do is control how we
respond to what the virus is doing and
what i would say to people is we're
going to have to be living with this
virus for quite a while that's just the
facts of the matter we're going to
continue to see new variants pop up
because it's going to be several years
quite frankly before we get the rest of
the world vaccinated but what we have
now are tools so that we can de-link
cases and variants from hospitalizations
and deaths
is there a danger and i know as you
mentioned it is it's going to take who
knows how long to get
say most of the world vaccinated
is that what it will take to finally get
a handle on covet having like most of
everyone in the world vaccinated or a
majority of people
and
you know until that day comes
are we just perpetually in danger of
having
more and potentially worse variants
emerge
well i think it's important for people
to understand that it is unlikely even
if we get a variant that is less
responsive to vaccines
then it will be completely
evasive of our current vaccines and so
i and many other scientists believe that
as we get more of the world vaccinated
and quite frankly as more of the world
gets exposed to this virus that people
will will have some sort of immunity
moving forward and you're going to see
again cases delinked from
hospitalizations that's the good news uh
but what we want people to understand is
that we don't want you naturally
encountering this virus and risking
hospitalization and death we want you to
get immunity the safest way possible and
that's through vaccinations and boosters
dr jerome adams former u.s surgeon
general thank you so much for your time
absolutely thank you and have hope have
hope because we have the tools we just
have to use them protect your family
this holiday season by uh just taking
simple precautions get the facts and
hopefully you'll get the backs that's
how we move forward
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from fox news listen and
download the fox news hourly update on
your time the trending stories you need
anytime you want it listen and download
now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com rate and review the
fox news rundown on apple podcasts or
wherever you listen it's time for your
fox news commentary
what's on your mind as illegal migrants
continue to stream across america's
southern border in record numbers the
biden administration has announced
trump-style travel bans affecting eight
southern african nations the
administration also instituted a vaccine
mandate for essential travelers legally
crossing the border including truck
drivers emergency response workers and
government officials
these new measures allegedly designed to
protect americans from the spread of the
emerging coven 19 omicron variant are
little more than political theater
under current biden administration
policies migrants detained at the
southern border are only being tested
for covid if they exhibit symptoms there
is no vaccine requirement for them that
means hundreds of thousands of people
are flooding into the country illegally
while truck drivers are prohibited from
doing their jobs unless they are
vaccinated at a time when a shortage of
drivers is hobbling already crippled
supply chains biden's new regulations
have a huge downside with very little
upside
according to unpublished u.s customs and
border protection numbers obtained by
the washington post
border apprehensions in 2021 reached the
highest levels ever recorded and the 1.3
million people taken into custody just
since president biden took office is
likely only a fraction of the total
number of illegal border crossers
among those are untold thousands of
african migrants some inevitably
originating from the very countries
affected by the travel ban
in 2019 when illegal migration levels
were much lower an estimated 5 000
people from 35 african nations were
taken into custody trying to cross into
the country illegally those are just the
ones who were caught
since then the number of migrants have
exploded
between 2012 and 2020 the border patrol
detained an average of 540 000 people
per year that is one-third the number
apprehended this year
the most recent data shows the number
detained just in the month of october
was a hundred and ninety two thousand
again a fraction of the total
how many of them were tested for covent
how many are expected to be vaccinated
biden's policies have real economic
consequences for the border economy
shutting down travel from other nations
checking vaccination status at the
border and mandating people inject an
experimental vaccine come with a price
paid in freedom opportunity and
prosperity
people were willing to pay that price
when they thought it would protect them
from a deadly virus
no one can say whether travel bans and
vaccine mandates
would be enough to protect americans
from a new unknown variant but we know
for certain those policies won't work
if they can be easily circumvented by
millions of illegal border crossers
putting us all at risk
i'm jason chaffetz fox news contributor
and host of the jason in the house
podcast
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there about the country and where
we're going subscribe to the ben dominic
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes